the team thinks I broke Conor's wrist on
purpose and I guess throwing my stuff in
the shower was retaliation he's going to
turn the whole school against me you
keep a stack with me
did you do it on purpose
[ __ ] he deserved that [ __ ] I'm proud of
you bro
look I'm just tired of his [ __ ] you
know but now it's like everyone hates me
the the looks the comments it's like me
when I first got out here
look man I'm sorry for the [ __ ] I
put you through being treated like this
sucks
it's okay man I'll sweat it right but
there's a way that you can get past this
I had to come out to Bel Air and build a
whole new social Kingdom from scratch
all right well Kingdom feels a little
like an over exaggeration but you know
what I'm saying you don't need Connor or
any of them I your Carlton [ __ ]
Banks baby
I
and I think I know a way for you to turn
this around
there you are oh you made it do you
think I missed the biggest party of the
Year funny
how did you get out the house did you
pop some sleeping pills in your dad's
coffee stop I told him I was hanging out
with Rachel which isn't totally a lie
I'm glad you made it
well I hope maybe in here it doesn't you
know cause trouble with you and your
uncle oh no they're not even here
they're gone for the weekend
my uncle your dad
they'll never know we were together so
we can get laid well not quite Carlton
still doesn't know about us
and I'm gonna tell them I promise I will
but the day he's been having
time is just off so
damn
I wish I could kiss you right now
and if somebody sees us
where is Carlton anyway
somewhere probably sober on The Struggle
Bus
and I've been trying to get them to have
some fun all night but every time I see
him he's alone well you know this is not
really his crowd
I mean
but uh got no matchmaking situation
going on so
let's see
okay we're right there and that that's
my favorite desk mine too oh you are so
much cooler than your rat oh what's my
rap
forget I said anything no no no come on
I can take it okay
they say you're kind of a sellout
the friends you hang with
the drugs you're into I mean you like
lacrosse and yachting and race cars
got it so because I like what I like I'm
disqualified from being black well it
doesn't help that you don't make an
effort to get down with us
look you've never even been to a BSU
meeting
that's not cool
enjoy the party Aisha
yo
what's going on bro hey Carlton there
you are guess party dude I'm I'm
surprised you guys showed like I thought
I was Public Enemy Number One or
something guess my invitation got lost
in the mail yo Connor what the [ __ ] are
you doing here shouldn't you be like at
home getting high on Vicodin
thank you for your concerned
John invited me
is that what this is about
I just wanted you guys to squash this
[ __ ]
that's it
all right fine
cool but after you apologize for all the
racist and offensive [ __ ] you've been
saying
and I don't mean just me all right like
the Asian jokes the Mexican jokes the
homophobic [ __ ] like cut it out
an apology you're so [ __ ] sensitive
you know what you're whack
and this is a weak ass party
let's take it back to my crib
no we're good
it's fine
you too
who's winning I got next
no reason
I drink all I want